Speaker 1: One other thing from Fox News that
is just laughable.
Fox Nation, which is the streaming network
for Fox News, they're doing a mock trial of
Hunter Biden.
No, no, no.
I didn't say Joe Biden.
They're doing a mock trial of Hunter Biden.
You know, they talk about impeaching Joe Biden,
to which we often say, for what?
For what?
For what.
But if they did a mock trial of Joe Biden,
at least Joe Biden's the president.
But that's not what they're doing.
They are doing a mock trial for Hunter Biden.
It's fiction programing.
Okay.
Take a look at this promo.
Speaker 5: Hunter Biden is the most protected
person in the country.
Speaker 1: White money laundering, illegal
foreign lobbying.
Speaker 2: You have the laptop, the infamous
big guy email.
The son of vice president is doing deals funded
by the Chinese government.
There are so.
Speaker 4: Many pieces of evidence.
The media has ignored it because they want
a Joe Biden elected president.
Ladies and gentlemen of the jury.
Speaker 2: I am here to defend Hunter Biden.
So we're attempting to influence policy.
Objection, Your Honor.
Let's look at photographs.
This is what I think of these photographs.
Speaker 5: You really have no way of knowing
what was said between him and these people.
Speaker 4: He committed.
Speaker 2: Bribery.
Your Honor, with you going to try my case,
try not to lose it.
At this time.
Speaker 4: The prosecution rests.
The trial of Hunter Biden.
Speaker 1: Streaming all this week.
Oh.
Oh, my goodness.
How can we even take this seriously?
You know, this could be so devastating.
I don't know that anyone's going to vote for
Hunter Biden after this program.
Oh, he's not running for anything.
Oh.
Fictional programing for their endlessly gullible
audience.
And again, we see these interviews at a Trump
rally, and these people are obsessed with
Hunter Biden.
And we're like, Why?
Where is this stuff coming from?
It's coming from places like this.
It's coming from this type of programing.
Mr. Biden, you're being charged with two counts
of a laptop from hell and two counts of the
Biden crime family.
How do you plea?
I really wish they would stop trying to make
this Hunter Biden stuff happen.
But it's also a reminder of how vapid and
vacant they're they are in terms of having
anything else.
They don't have anything else to work with.
This is all they have at this point in time.
And yes, I know Marjorie Taylor GREENE and
Lauren Boebert say that they're going to impeach
Joe Biden.
Okay.
They seem they all seem much, much more focused
on Hunter Biden.
It's pathetic.
It's humiliating.
And again, remember, one of the ways in which
Fox News has become what it is and Fox Nation
is the streaming arm of Fox News.
One of the ways they've done it.
Is they blur the lines between reality and
fiction, and they blur the lines between news
and opinion and.
Do we call this a film?
I don't know.
But I don't know if it's a series or a film.
This mock trial of Hunter Biden is the epitome
of appealing to low information folks who
lack all media literacy.
Blurring opinion and news.
Fact and fiction.
And hopefully nobody watches it.
It looks like it's going to be a complete
and total disaster